thanks for joining us America Rachael is
in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Rachael
where are you from I am from Fort
Lauderdale Florida welcome to Nashville
it's good to have you and you're here to
do your debt-free screen absolutely
wouldn't miss it love it love it love it
how much have you paid off I paid all
twenty nine thousand eight hundred and
thirty seven dollars and thirty four
cents cool how long did that take you
twelve months very good making what kind
of money a little over eighty thousand
eighty plus what you do for a living I'm
in sales for a fortune 500 insurance
company oh cool good for you
excellent so what kind of debt was the
30 K uh Dave I was normal I had student
loans and I was one of the ones that
took out living expenses even though I
was living at home near in college and
took out the extra money there was a car
loan in there there was credit cards
department stores just different types
of credit cards car outstanding medical
bills and one parking ticket good lord
so you make you're making really good
money I mean you make an 80k yeah and
yet all these little ankle-biter things
are adding up and adding up and adding
up so tell me the story what happened
twelve months ago that set your hair on
fire because you went after it yeah well
it actually started about three years
ago I took Financial Peace University I
did the envelope system but I wasn't
very serious and then twelve months ago
I was kind of staring down the barrel of
my 30th birthday this is ridiculous
I'm paying half of my income basically
to every month to build so I made a goal
that by last December the December that
just passed I wanted to be debt-free I
started last January and any bonus that
I got from work every little thing I was
just putting towards debt my 30th
birthday was last May and then December
I became debt-free Sal right so the idea
was in the 30th year that was the plan
to be clear and you made it halfway
through way to go oh yeah so it was just
kind of a life phase wake-up call then
it was you know I think for at thirty I
felt like I was making decent money and
you know I I just felt like I wasn't
really where I wanted to be it was
ridiculous that I had so much student
loans when I graduated college so long
ago you know I had the money I just
wasn't really following the plan I was
actually still doing the envelope system
I still I just wasn't put
that if for me the money in the bank was
security and I was afraid to go down to
that you know the thousand dollars in
the six months because I had built up a
little bit of a nest egg so when I had
to write those checks to pay the student
loans off and the other debt it was a
little bit nerve-racking but it's so
much better now it's easier to sleep at
night now that I don't owe anybody money
it changes everything don't it yeah very
cool and as a salesperson it's weird
when you don't have any bills it changes
the sale process doesn't it it does yeah
you're not really desperate to make the
sale yeah desperate salespeople smell
bad yeah that's amazing
so what do you tell people when they
find out you paid off thirty thousand
dollars and that in one year and they
say how do you do that what do you tell
them the secret is I would say the
secret is discipline you know I had to
learn a different some some different
disciplines that maybe I hadn't
practiced before for me one thing that I
got really really great out is couponing
and so I was able to save sixty to
seventy percent a month on my grocery
bill or the money that I was saving each
when I would go to the grocery store at
the bottom of the receipt whatever it
told me it would say I saved from
coupons I would throw it towards debt so
that was kind of one way that I was able
to gain a little bit of traction and I
saw a lot of little wins doing that but
it's it's possible you just have to be
disciplined because you make plenty of
money man you lived on 50k that's no
slouch and pay thirty I mean that's
doable it's very doable you just had to
control you and you know the good news
is you didn't have anybody to control
but you the bad news is you don't have
anybody to control but great and nobody
nobody to yell at you or nobody to blame
if it didn't go well
that's true but you don't have to
convince anybody to do this yeah you
just went after it yes
well congratulations thank you so did
people make fun of you or did you have
more cheerleaders you know I had a lot
of cheerleaders I think sometimes people
thought you know when I would go out to
eat with them and I was pulling out my
cash envelope for my restaurant envelope
or something like that they thought it
was a little bit crazy but I think
overall people were encouraging you know
a lot of people would say wow that's
crazy
good luck to you you know yeah so you're
crazy
yeah so but overall I think supporters
okay so not it's not any real hardcore
people whining or anything is that kind
of
very cool well congratulations very very
proud of you it's an honor to meet you
you're obviously a rock star thank you
very well done all right Rachel from
Fort Lauderdale Florida $30,000 paid off
in 12 months making 80 thousand a year
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two one I'm debt free
well done that's how you do it right
there folks
without a doubt that's how you do it
well done Rachel hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you are not a victim
you're not a victim of big corporations
you're not a victim of Wall Street
you're not a victim of capitalism you're
not a victim of wealth inequality you're
not a victim of racism you're not a
victim